hello welcome to maestro commentaries
for x-men dank Phoenix yeah that's right
I'm supposed to be a Gilbert Joe
Danielle Dan well and if you are
watching this video you're getting our
behind the scenes thoughts or thought
process and cut jokes
some deleted scenes and a tease for next
week's honest trailer that's what's
happening in this video yeah this was a
movie some films are tough to kind of
get our hooks in for an honest trailer
you know what's the real underlying
thesis what's our premise what do we
what's our take this one was really a
soft ball down the middle that's
old-school crappy movie happy superhero
movie like oh man my I was just
salivating when this one came out how do
you guys feel oh well Joe how do you
feel this movie almost broke you oh it
broke Joe Wow
complete blue screen no no I like this
movie you and the rest of America slash
the world this is a really bad movie I
just the first 10 minutes I was like
what's everyone talking about like this
isn't that bad yes I will say the first
10 minutes I had the exact same reaction
I was like wait this was the worst film
of beer no they're there in space yeah
they're working as a team it's like the
x-men are going on a mission together
I've never seen them has them even from
the very beginning I went here we go
again and I looked right at the camera
and went it's a living
yeah I just don't see where that because
for me the x-men is where they've been
not misguided but where they've
succeeded and failed as they pin all
their hopes on one character usually
Wolverine lately mystique it's all about
you know they pick a protagonist they
pick a hero and it's harder to write
this way but the x-men should be about
the group yeah it should be about all of
them you should be balancing their
motivations and their wants and their
needs and stuff like that
but they just seem to all hang it on
someone's blue head and it yeah that
every other character is kind of
sidelined but yes this first ten minutes
like oh they're a team I was watching
this and I was like they cracked it yeah
they did it make for you now to make an
x-men movie and I will give you it is
cool that they finally said oh there are
other x-men but the fact that that
sequence was just look oh you went it's
like oh my god there's other x-men like
the animated series does it beautifully
like the big action sequences hey
there's a cool thing happening right
here but then in the in the background
game buts throwing an alien across the
way and that guy just that came up and
over and then row punched him and then
they fell in like there's just there's
it's exciting to watch and engaging and
even in the comics still photos like
still drawings have more animation and
movement to them than this opening 10
minute sequence just all of them sitting
on a on--is in chairs well no I mean
Raven was sitting there in chairs yeah
because she has no sorry occasionally
someone would teleport into the the very
still spaceship and and hug someone and
make them appear back into the room
where everyone was sitting in chairs it
was just very boring to me Hey I
disagree wholeheartedly but I will agree
that the Ravens presence we talked about
this is like beast knew how to fly the
ship Cyclops
used his optic blast storm used her
powers Nightcrawler used his powers
Quicksilver use his powers and then it's
like what is Raven doing there like
quickly shape-shift didn't to fool him
distracted crawler saves him she could
have done all of that from the chair she
could have been girl in the chair and
then all of the
from home there was no reason to get her
in the spacesuit and send her in space
or and we'll get into it again the the
mistake of everyone just being like
Mystique's important in matters like
Cyclops could have led the team because
apparently he's had 10 years to lead the
team we didn't get to see any of that
some time has passed we'll talk about
time job solid stuff I feel like we
could talk for hours probably about the
first 10 minutes alone so let's get any
on tomorrow no area start and stop as we
see fit yeah I'm sure there will be many
times
[Music]
from Disney comes the last film in this
X universe to remind us that just like
the human body when a franchise dies it
craps itself
[Music]
pause so how many poop jokes are too
many poop jokes was was on that topic
last week I think do you if we count
this as one overarching poop joke I'm
okay with it I usually think one or
fewer is appropriate you can treat going
back you can't go full grown-ups with it
I didn't see their owner that well it's
a single poop joke and our editor Kevin
who has fantastic instincts and is right
all the time and is a needed
counterpoint to this suggested that we
do farts like every time I'd like to see
the fart cut yeah I do want to see the
park cut I mean that's what we were
given in theaters so I would have liked
to have seen the honest trailer fart cut
yes I just thought we got all our farts
out of the way early and we could we can
move on from there but I still think
there's too many there's a little when
we go out of the title that was
originally at the beginning that I think
I know I I had them back to the I meant
it though I missed it after it was gone
well yeah no I moved it back because
there was a it very much looks like
you're going into a bottle so let's keep
playing see if you can see this a third
is far too many are emmy-nominated work
we were talking about if they have not
lost to carpool karaoke for the second
consecutive year that's right
the second let it go it's an honor to be
nominated it is and I would have been
happy to lose to any of the other
nominees that are me and the beyhive we
have that in common
yeah but we I think we talked about if
you know our weird alternate reality we
had won the Emmy we were going to have
John picked something up and just feel
like that Timmy went in content right
with the farts well you're not even at
the Emmys this past weekend there was a
very sort of like imposter syndrome
feeling of all of us in very nice
clothes at this very nice party we don't
belong to and in the back of my head
knowing that the next day we're gonna
come into work and really make some
final calls move that fart later please
next year oh Jenny asleep okay keep
going
pingzhi anus laid eyes on the latest
x-men joint and IP it's given us the
highest highs the lowest lows and the
midlist meds to revisit the Dark Phoenix
storyline from x-men 3 only this time we
really get to know Jean Grey no really I
mean it's an interesting thing to think
about or to just hash out because the
movie is entirely about Jean Grey and
yet I feel like I don't know anything
about anything about her what we learn
about her in this that is played like
big reveals for her character is really
mostly like the ways Charles effed with
her head and yeah and lied to her about
the true facts of her parents death
which is a piece of a puzzle right
mm-hmm but I don't there's she popped up
at the apocalypse and had about ten
minutes and then we go right to like the
most dramatic important thing that ever
happens in her life
they just take for granted that we
already know this story because they
they've done it once very simple nothing
but someone else did it once very
successfully and then it was done in the
comics very well and then they tried it
again and then they try to no again and
they just take for granted that we
already know and like Jean without
actually making it new who just walked
in to this franchise and you didn't know
anything else about the x-men you'd be
like why do I care about what happened
to this but this is the thing though
this is it's almost worse than that of
like an unforced error because they did
do groundwork for this in the last movie
like this whole set up a tiny bit but
yeah
she has this force inside of her and
Charles is in her head she's like I see
a pot see this this world ending fire
like they started laying the groundwork
for this movie in the last movie and
then in this movie like never mind it's
a thing in the space and they completely
disregard anything they did that was the
last that wasn't the last iteration that
wasn't the last franchise that was the
last movie and they just released like
remembering a giant fiery Phoenix shot
out of it and stopped epochal that's my
thing it's like what they're walking
around Houston and Cyclops is like oh
did you hear it they're calling you now
they're calling you the Phoenix like
really now they're calling again nine
years ago when she made a huge Phoenix
appear maybe that's when they should
start calling your feet franchise and
this oh no no I all I want to do is yell
I hate these movies this is also my
problem like trying to write on this one
was just like stay on target stay on -
because I just have what you did
discover this that Joe hates all of the
x-men way more than the rest of us I do
on because I love I love the x-men
here's the problem especially with a
reboot first class on OK none of them
accomplished anything they're supposed
to do the the decade hopping means
you're skipping any anything that's
gonna make me care about the x-men and
then you're just doing the greatest hits
Days of Future past why do I care that
their reality is gonna get destroyed I
just learned about hoola-hoop havoc and
the the c-listers that you relaunched
with first class I just met them why do
I care now that they have to make a
sacrifice and change their future but I
don't because I don't know anything
about them apocalypse came and went the
world ended like the world got leveled
and I don't know the x-men have a phone
everybody really likes them no one
really comments on it it doesn't matter
the Phoenix doesn't matter and then with
this movie the the point of the Phoenix
saga is that you've spent 20-some 10 15
20 years of comics like falling in love
with Jean Grey and then a weird Firebird
takes over her body and then the
Hellfire Club who you also
up in this franchise already and then
just completely disregarded and ignored
[ __ ] screws with her head they make her
evil she does something really horrible
and then the team has to make the moral
decision as to whether or not to stand
with their friend or hold her
responsible for this horrible thing that
she did that's the point but these
movies don't get it they're just like
Days of Future past is an important name
you know I don't know God loves man
kills is an important thing you know
there's no context we don't care just
put the title on it and that's this
movie 100% like felt that way was the
last two I will agree this is Future
past I'll stick up for I like that movie
and I think it it also it almost makes
these two movies worse because I like
first class it kind of filled in the
gaps of the origin and I liked Ellie did
that and then I thought Days of Future
past actually very well merged these two
things and it sort of put a bow on the
future and was sort of that the baton
handing the baton off to this new
franchise and they just immediately
dropped as short and then stopped to
pick it up dropped it again fell down
yeah tripped the other runners in the
race
passed out they completely had a wide
open feet just like goodwill everything
in their favor and they immediately just
fouled it up yes
horribly to the point where it lies to
to movies and then yeah it's done you
finally like the only redeemable thing
about Apocalypse was at the very end
everyone finally gets a neat looking
costume and then they went right back to
their starter jackets like from first
class and it's like I you could have at
least given me the the Gimli Cyclops
costume like if you're not gay I'm not
usually a person who's like I see the
thing that I like so I'm excited but
it'll if you're not gonna give me
anything else please give me that
matches and bomber jackets
yeah but otherwise it's just a lady
going meat or nothing
small feeding pouches or nothing instead
it's just mystique being like why are we
putting these children that have a
danger room in danger and nothing makes
sense enough so we're 50 also yes I
would like to point out and again it has
been established that these x-men are
canonically the same x-men that grow up
and we are now in 1992 because they
chose to hop decades for no reason where
we are now eight years from Professor X
supposedly looking Patrick's tragic
Stewart again it's not me saying like
though it's a different freshly no they
went out of their way to specific to
specify that these are the exact same
people and yet for no reason whatsoever
complete nonsense reason they've said it
in the 90s for again no pay their next
mission is on the surface of the Sun
it's gonna require some weird Rick and
Morty after like mojo world was a doozy
okay let's get go okay but we're
exploring that cosmic potential of the
Phoenix force know after the intro it's
on earth okay fine yeah sorry big part
of the Phoenix saga is that she actually
does some good with it at first yeah the
m'kraan crystal and all that stuff yeah
it's like you give her this awesome
infinite wellspring of power and it's so
clearly the wrong idea and evil right
from the get-go there's you know drama
there's the conflict yeah this is
missing well you're setting yourself up
for the highest stakes and any extra
movie ever and as you pointed out I
think we're I forget who but it ends in
the lowest stakes battle which is
literally the battle across the street
oh the panel
time to get to gene it's literally just
like I guess they're in New York yes and
they're in like Central Park and genes
on the other side magneto makes it
across first any [ __ ] he puts a truck
in front of the door no but I feel like
most x-men can deal with that you mean
the laser eye guy but then the [ __ ] just
hair guy he's facing down Jean Grey and
it's like oh damn magneto Jean Grey the
two most part he's gone oh yeah again
it's the space thing you know in the
comics it's you introduced the Shiar
Empire and when she when she gets
corrupted and turns back she blows up
like a populated planet yet like she
kills a billion people yeah and I'm not
saying you have to do like the
full-scale cosmic here comes a whole
space Empire blah blah blah I'm not
saying you have to do that but you at
least have to give us the equivalent
like maybe in the last movie she ends up
if you're gonna do it right we take a
movie to meet Jean and a little less
mystique then she gets the Phoenix force
she becomes all-powerful and the worlds
like yeah she look at all this cool
stuff she's doing and then at some point
in the show she flips two cop cars yeah
factor is they're putting mutants in
internment camps because a good guy car
they dropped RFK Stadium on the White
House a decade ago and magneto got to go
live on a farm and a kid has two decades
ago identity to go magneto pulled all
the metal out of the earth and destroyed
killed hundred million thousands of
people and again didn't know Kennedy was
trying to save him oh but you just
caused massive destruction on a
worldwide scale
no internment camps gene literally flips
three cop cars and they're like up a
helicopter like this number is
disconnected Charles clinically put them
in camp brain like trains yeah but you
had a force capable yeah of the kind of
power that would make blow up
government say we're putting Newton's
yeah she should blow the city or some
young lady no it's just city you cowards
full parallax yeah it's it seems lazy
isn't it's not yes that it's it's not
the common it's that you have all the
ingredients there and then they choose
to just go the easiest route with it
it's like you and the whole the whole
character conflict is like Jean this is
not who you are but like yeah no [ __ ]
she's not like a genocide 'el maniac
like what is that what are they arguing
over yeah yeah for who Jean is this in
mind the last movie had Xavier saying oh
this is not who you aren't she had like
oh sure when the big blue guys got you
pinned down in his mind palace it's
unleash your power when the roid raisins
gotcha when he she's about to find out
you lied to her it's Jean hang on hold
bag on and also like Jean this is not
who you are who is she I don't know you
have not told us she's like turn she
said she's a grown woman who hangs out
with teens in the woods the teachers
should drink it everywhere Professor X
is getting bombed in his office the
Beast is getting bombed in the kitchen
then the kids are all hanging out in the
woods and the teachers are like pumping
the kick what kind of school is well
Dazzler in 1992 is singing like a modern
day like EDM song like yeah this is
horribly run school where's Harry's
hideaway is it God I'd go to a bar yeah
you can't just supposed to be playing
softball like Chris Claremont intended
we're never gonna get to know now keep
going okay boy it was terrible to
finally see what a new creative team can
do with this material
no sane guy who wrote x-men last hand
but now he's directing - all right
[Laughter]
so look what's Bryan Singer's supposed
to direct this and he dropped no so this
was all the studio's choice from the
get-go cuz and I apparently I haven't I
haven't read the stuff on it but people
have been sending us things that are
like oh well Jennifer Lawrence like
insisted that if he did not direct this
that she would quit okay three scenes in
anyway whatever was that her attempted
on the French that's good
yep she just straight she was like
really trying to scone their bluff or
stick the director Simon Kinberg called
her up and it's like I've written this
great line for you about changing the
name of the ex she was like I have to
deliver that line yes off immediately
call it the ex women because it's the
women who saved the men you know it's a
terrible construction and it's it's it's
really the worst line you could imagine
and it's not the sentiment although the
sentiments a little trihard I don't like
that either but it's like and by the way
it's the men that as the women are
always saving the men around here so
maybe you should change the name to ex
women just as a punch line you gave the
punch line away earlier in the sentence
sure so it's just poorly constructed
because like if you want to like I mean
I don't want to be mr. masterclass here
but I'm maximum impact we have lots more
Emmys in case you haven't noticed we're
the ones who are saving them in Iran
here so maybe you should change the name
to ex women yeah easy peasy
there you go is way better than her by
the way in case you haven't noticed the
women are always saving the men around
here so you might as well change the
name to ex women uh-huh uh-huh you just
I knew what you were gonna say because
you just gave it away early like it's
just poor construction it's not the
sentiment it's the it's it's it's like
the Seinfeld it offends me as a comedian
yeah sorry
also Nightcrawler say Jean Grey's life
and they've just landed from a mission
where the beast piloted a ship into
space and the Nightcrawler saved Jean
Grey from the vacuum of space with a
space helmet that Quicksilver duct tape
under Nightcrawler
so it's actually her
her sentence is also he was truly the
only person who didn't need to be she
was the only superfluous member of that
crew she that's the other thing the
balls on her to go on their demand they
changed name to ex women after she
bravely sat in the copilot seat and did
nothing on a space rescue mission and
then why Charles why did you send us to
rescue people and he's like well because
we want you know you're you signed up
for this year at x-men and you're 50 and
this is a this is so that people won't
get mad at us and put us in camps
granted he didn't seem to do that anyway
right but Oh Charles oh he's just so
like you what do you know you like going
to the White House and getting medals
from the president the trains but
compared to the alternative yeah I'm
sorry that you're bothered that I have
to go to the White House and have a
hotline to the president do you think
Xavier was ever talking to the president
and he was like oh so what's this train
you keep thinking about every time you
by the way Raven you were one bullet
away from all of us being killed by
mutant hunting robots in 20 years so why
should get off your high horse and go
get impaled on a house he's going
there's so much boobies terrible you
know what they say is drinking once
shame on you fool me twice and you could
probably fool me again because I like
the cartoon and nerds are easy marks
they didn't see this one x-men no just
kidding doesn't matter because no one
will explain how or why magneto is a
free man after the last movie or how the
expose Magneto's farm
I am question well they are growing food
the weird thing about it is it's not a
prison because they come and go as they
please know that federal government has
granted them this land because the thing
that's super weirded me out about it was
like it seems like like a refuge like a
peaceful place where mutants who don't
want to be part of the world where it
seems like they're pretty well
to get a weird reveal and they were
savage landing it in Antarctica and he
like run off yeah yeah Genosha Genosha
yeah yeah well we had a bet was the I
guess it's a leased beast comes to tell
him that that Jean Grey someone who he's
met maybe once or twice as far as no I'm
assuming they've had a million great
adventures in the ten years that they
chose not to show us and I believe he
showed up after generation up from out
of nowhere worth blood on her shirt and
then they had a helicopter which we'll
talk about they fought over a helicopter
and then he's like get out of here I'm
just tired to imagine the the missing
scenes here where beast is like there's
this you know Jean sort of she's she's a
bit of a loose cannon we need you to go
kill her he's like okay and then there
had to be another conversation where he
talks to his inmates his like friends
and he's like guys you mean hair guy
yeah hair guy there's Debbie girl I know
we're all like enjoying our refuge but I
need to go murder a stranger you all are
cool with coming with me and help trust
me she's a threat like what is his role
there why are they he's murder squad
okay fine
I know he's angry but they're not like
the House of M they're not like his
Magneto's henchmen they're farmers and
they all just show up to murder scene
the the easiest solve to that is went on
your whiteboard
it says where's magneto after pulling
all the metal out of the world hiding
with his followers sure and so easy fix
then someone's like hey magneto we
really needed to kill this lady and his
cult followers are like work hulks I
know the one thing we know about them is
they're like we want to be left alone
yes
here guys just been itching to go man
also I'm sorry hair guy you're not like
you you don't need to be it's a [ __ ]
you can just not make your hair do snake
dances and you finally get a job in
marketing just trim even get afro
shampoo can he control all of his hair
we'll never know because the director
writer created him out of all so no one
is at Finnegan that's another thing with
these that's it oh that's the thing he
did with x3 was like there was a spiky
lady yeah like Wolverine was running
around in the woods by the way another
movie where Jean Grey went to go find
magneto in the woods after she's got a
Phoenix force come on dude I think was
did a find replace but yeah that's
another thing he does it's like you have
there's there's so many mutants that
Marvel Comics had to be like what if we
did a thing where there were no more
mutants because they was getting
unwieldy like there's no reason why
there's spiky guy hair man or man like
give maggot some love Jubilee
disappeared okay keep going his movies
are terrible yeah we're gonna get the
last moves could be a new record how the
x-men have a hotline to the president
after this happened or why they keep
skipping decades even though it puts
these characters cause it'll be it'll be
yes
even if magneto was secretly curving the
bullet away they still think he tried to
kill he was he was imprisoned under the
Pentagon killed anyways he told Charles
II was Chinese now he's on a farm also I
saw some qualms about the fact that we
showed mystique pointing a gun at Nixon
saying after this happened well in the
movie yes she never technically pointed
the gun at Nixon but we were trying to
get a point a point across in two
seconds that the x-men had dropped a
stadium on the White House and almost
killed the president and having him you
point a gun at the president seemed the
clothes the mass dissuade but I see that
we've been called is like can you at
least be intellectually honest in your
that was a very quick way to get our
point across so I if you don't I gave
the order huh I gave the order I gave
the order to cheat that shot it was a
way to get our point across quickly come
with it then I hold the intellectual
honesty that this deserves was in the
beginning with the farts fifties
whatever pretend this is the first one
you've seen and thrill as Jean Grey
fights an evil space cloud of monotone
space alien if we can control that power
we can resurrect our race begin again in
American accent I don't have you made
sure that it is are you caring there's
some everyone's doing an accent in this
movie like just cast people yet they can
do it the Brits are doing American
Australians are doing German whatever
Alexander strippers ship is doing very
excess dorm which is not an African
accent I don't know what it was she
don't either and I don't think a lot of
people like she can't act and it's like
I dare most people to take this script
and make it good
also telepaths would you speak ever no
you just do it in people's heads yeah
it's just me I had a D key I don't know
I I would just be like and you'd be like
do you want cheese and I'd be like yeah
maybe like I shouldn't even math course
you wouldn't you'd be Silent Bob just
Silent Bob it hey keep good greet and a
say for this it's almost like focusing
almost deke for the last three movies
was now hear me out a bad choice mutant
I'm proud audience and over it they
sometimes more x-men haven't come to
expect them by now
annoyed bored as always a speech and
nobody cares anymore
Amen away too famous to sit for makeup
but they'll step aside to give the New
Mutants something to do or rather these
mutants like Cyclops who's random f-bomb
in a pg-13 movie is the closest he comes
to a personality if you touch her I will
[ __ ] kill you like silver causes of
everyone Cyclops I guess it has the most
impact peace he's the last person who
would say a swear no that night that's
the thing though he's not Nightcrawler
would be I mean they turn him into a
murderer but it's like Cyclops you don't
even know him it's like if if they if he
did in the 90s cartoon then my goodness
yes that's quite effective main I don't
know maybe this is maybe the Cyclops
custom Oh Brian can I no no maybe the
Cyclops cusses all the time we don't
know anything about him - when your
monetization post maybe in the past ten
years he's just become yeah
you can adjust your letters to YouTube
it gives you Kirsty on main maybe in the
last 10 years he's just gotten real blue
like he saw delirious and and and that
really kind of changed the course of his
personality I don't know we don't know
anything about them no big an Andrew
Dice Clay at this point reduc my optic
blast oh has any character earned an
f-bomb through these series of movies
like magneto has me my god they put him
through the wringer like spender the
f-bomb yeah yeah this little punk he'll
do the finger in one ass dude he's been
in like one of the half movies give
magneto the f-bomb he's been through
that they killed his daughter with an
arrow raised wife at the same time with
the same arrow right and he's just
digging stuff out of the gif gift fast
bend to the bomb he'll put some stank on
it also I think that like he's not a
like a kid or just learned how to curtsy
yeah he's been did he hook up with Jean
Grey at the end of Apocalypse like were
they a couple at that point they were
already together already together so
they do
for ten years and they work together and
like and they still live in the dorm
still party with the kids
yeah the x-men have always part in the
wild they live in a house on the grounds
it's just the way he's playing it or the
way it's written is like don't touch my
girl bro but it's like yeah that's like
your common-law wife let it go a 90-89
you know you're 800 ball in psychic
rapport over there let's get out of my
head gee they'll take the trash out you
know the 10th anniversary is the m'kraan
enemies get a piece of a reality char
you lose that energy even if you're a
bore and more in love you just the way
they're playing it it's like they're
still in high school literally in a high
state they're writing him like he's in
his second movie which he is but they're
also writing him as if this movie took
place the year after the last movie
which would make sense but doesn't
because for some reason again they're
obsessed with jumping a decade movie so
they're writing characters who are
living wives 10 to 30 years behind where
they should be at this point so yeah
it's a big ol mess hot mess a hot mess
give Co mosquito once again sideline
before his powers make everyone else
point leanest relies quite so quick
quickly i crawler who's gone from
thriller fan to killer man it's got to
carve a bunch of sins into his face so
condition to have nothing to do that she
lets it pour rain at a Funeral just make
it stop raining over you did the funeral
yeah at least give yourself a respite
story with an umbrella is the dumbest
thing I've ever seen maybe they asked
her for rain like you know we need some
external manifestation remember when the
story was that actress had the gall to
be like they wasted us that was the did
she tweet that or something that must
have been the day where she was like hey
Simon why am i holding an umbrella when
I'm storming
that was probably the day she was like
and this is the stupidest and just cuz I
do know that one thing that does happen
is the weather sometimes if when storm
can't control her powers she will affect
the weather she should still not be
using an umbrella right she's also in
ten years of practice yeah I don't know
or hmm
hear me out because movie and dramatic
moments and things like that it's not
raining and then storm gets very upset
and rain happens and you go storm is
very upset just a nephew to Raven
because like you know you would think
like at the very least maybe they would
think like well at least the last memory
we have of Raven is this beautiful
memorial service on the sunny warm
temperate day we have this wonderful
lasting memory and storms like screw her
it's gonna rain
I don't my lines man I'm really
hamstrung by this monetizing ban curse
curse Dan Curtis take the next x-men
probably something like this because
this is the directors first movie and
he's spending two hundred million
dollars on his student film showing off
exactly how superhero actors look if
it's not handled with care and expertise
morons they look like absolute morons
you're trying to open a jar with your
mind so that you do harder harder
[Applause]
it's if you took the behind-the-scenes
of you know like the Avengers behind the
scenes and you see Olsen going like this
with no Scarlet Witch effects
that's this movie but it's the movie
yeah and I went back to revisit Last
Stand and it's the same thing man it's a
it's it's the the pre effects reels of
Doctor Strange must look a lot of it
yeah but then someone was like that's
the movie maybe ya know it's it's a poop
off whip between Jean Grand Prix at the
end of last and they're just staring at
each other and I'm sure in the script
it's like waves of psychic energy or
damping the stage of parts are metal
strong yeah it's just cutting back and
forth between their crap face it's like
the South Park and I love that yeah
they still have to do the James McAvoy
this is not meant enha hang on Oh penny
Mambo number 5 yeah
yes Raven what you're not coming through
what say it again Raven wait hang on
hang on I can't hear you what what oh
yes thank you
I have a call on the other line good
times all right good good pay respects
to the final terrible movie of the
current x-men franchise that's a hero
shine on the writer/director failing
upwards or last minute reshoots to make
it less like Captain Marvel or the main
cast wishing they were dead
now the only ones left or you could
choose to remember all the good times
forget this ever happened and any tribe
reading some x-men comics instead but
you know they made books out of all
these movies there's even pictures
inside very good
starring Lady Bird Charlie in the child
soldier Factory
let's see them aliens all magneto
understood and it tells you who has
internet brain poisoning and who doesn't
it's the area 51 Facebook group of we're
gonna store Mary 51 we're gonna see than
are I knew about that it's all about
let's say the millions I the only the
advantage of this was also that I think
even less people noticed that her name
is buck because someone says it once
very quietly in a wide shot yep yeah
you'll see the alter you know the main
villain
yeah of the thing in the exciting
someone goes oh books here keep going
x-men origins Frazier close the Raven
please no more
taser face you gotta go fast Jake
Gyllenhaal I was I found that the movie
neck bones and the MCU stealing the
x-men oh I get it
x-men 4x3 take to the last one pause
this is X 4 because this is the fourth
in its reverse class yes this one it's
for a movie of the current franchise the
second take of the third x-men movie and
three the last one that was had a lot of
folks that were like it's not the fourth
one it was well in you know from a
certain point from a certain point of
venison yes thank you go gene did not
have this much blood on her where she
flew away whose blood is this
Jeanne did you kill Cyclops off screen
again your choice Devon play shirt
I guess awho bow I saw that season and I
remembered like I thought it flying off
his like wait a minute like did Raven
like like was it like a like a like like
like a Tom Savini thing like where we're
in Raven went back the blood just was
like just Raven like grabber bats are
far away like there's no blood there
she's a little on her hands and when I
doubt they're so worried about the blood
she wouldn't do like this so it's like
she flew into a bird a Phoenix if you
will mm-hmm okay let's see the deleted
scenes starring ginger snapped 50 genes
of gray like Sophie burner that's
telekinesis Kyle Charles in Charge -
[ __ ] be a lady - OH
bleuer Nick Holt barf Raven small
Hardiman magazine hey that's not very
Rabin
the goggles they do nothing it's not a
big nerd kid big down was a witness
you wanna know how I got these scars
self-mutilation pretty bleak right
remember that from X - no ma'am there it
is
judge dreads and he whips his hair back
and forth a with it hair back a timely
Willow Smith the last raw they'll strap
in eggs yeah a lot of these oh yeah
next man Fox x-men age of extinction
hey where's Jubilee did she just bail
yeah I respect that
am ia wait you renamed the school after
the lady who murdered its co-founder
that's pretty cold else we just hung
about New York that's gonna blow off I
have a big thing with that like raven
was Charles's childhood friend
yeah a literal co-founder of the x-men
and at the end of the movie they mention
grab you the school after the person who
as unwilling as it was murdered her
she's got pretty high body count she
murdered her parents too that is oh yeah
that is cold blows cop cars so yeah she
make it's three cop cars so you should
get to school yes that works two lives
two crown vics on a record let's run
through and thank God you see her flying
across the sky at the end yes yeah so
some quick user comments Montes Amma
3:14 who the hell thought the same guy
wrote the last and should write what's
essentially the Ray Bank hmm I guess
never Lawrence did [ __ ] I think that his
wife Fox trusts him for better or worse
is he produced Logan and produced
Deadpool but he wrote x3 and he wrote
fan-forced you know different jobs just
because your look producers do all sorts
of different things some are very
involved some are just there let you be
the judge I know everyone's always like
and he's such a huge fan and it's like
okay so are people who think triple H
should play Sabretooth and like that
Arnold should have been Colossus there
are a lot of football fans who have
never and should never take a snap yeah
that's how that works
my favorite of the producers was Lauren
Shuler Donner has been contractually
attached to these films because she was
a way back way way way way back to the
beginning she helped develop the
original x-men movies and she I think
publicly like right into the movie came
out was just like I was not involved in
this movie at all like don't at me don't
talk to me I was not there no
involvement not me like she's just like
publicly was like nope oh and the
deleted
all right sentiment so she you know hard
Shuler Donner name on the movie not
involved I just want to address the
first part of this person's come at the
death male rights to be fair since this
was sabotage should we really blame Fox
yes 100% okay there it's not there's not
a pristine series of films that just
collide into this crap heap like they
they were progressively getting worse
and worse and more nonsensical like yeah
this film was not sabotaged by the mouse
like it was bad it was bad apocalypse
was bad different opinions on Days of
Future past but even though they were
enjoyable things in it it was supposed
to be a reboot that still didn't even
accomplish that they're not know cuz I'm
not sabotage so I mean converges on said
just like this is the script I wrote
it's like yeah it's like he wasn't he
wasn't on set like hey does anyone have
eyes on lilandra in the Imperial Guard
[Laughter]
this didn't happen graduate they reshot
the third act because they love trains
in this franchise for some reason but it
didn't have the feeling of like a studio
disaster in the sense that like oh it's
so scattered like like the predator or
something like that where it's like oh
it feels like eighteen different this
feels like one consistently bad movie
that really over emphasized how much of
a good story they could tell about Jean
Grey and because we they keep just
repeating the same scenes over and over
again now about Jean marketing-wise you
can make that argument cuz I do remember
they put out a trailer with a release
date and literally the next day changes
the release date so I could say
marketing wise we could there could be a
discussion about whether or not Disney
fully committed and how they are and
then the raven death like
yeah the director revealing the biggest
death in the movie of when the first
trailer came out which was odd or the
second trailer but I think they knew
they had a stinker on their hands
trailer I saw I'd say 80% of it were was
older x-men movies and then it was like
the last 20% like see how it all ends
like there's less the more you see of
this movie the more you're gonna hate it
so just let's just think back alright a
few other things let's say we we touched
that Rab nerd 28 rights we're just gonna
ignore the fact Australia's never did
first class any reason why no not really
no real take on it yeah haven't had the
reason two years we've talked about this
but on the schedule a few times but then
we look at it and we all kind of look at
each other and shrug our shoulders and
go like oh yes yeah let's do the cartoon
instead yes I think we was yeah and
we're like it was more interesting to do
the 90's animated series so someday yeah
that bottom of that barrel will be
scraped oh we're gonna scrape that out
of the bottom yeah don't worry the
decade thing was interesting they should
just stop with it instead of jumping
decades yeah yeah so the cast was the
characters were weird but here's to uh
here's to new beginnings you guys I got
Phoenix god willing we're still allowed
to do this show did a couple years from
now when the MCU gets their hands on it
and and does another take and if not you
know it ended with big old turd just
like this show Spencer Dan Danielle Joe
thank you for joining us and thank you
audience and please come back next week
when we will be uncovering mysterious
new franchise in the making yeah you
know it's very cryptic oh yeah you know
I think I think our smarter smarter
viewers can decode yeah what that one
will be yeah okay we'll see you then
thanks for watching bye bye
[Music]